so happy to be standing here with Kevin
Feige producer of Marvel's Avengers age
of Ultron how are you feeling tonight
after so much anticipation for this film
I'm feeling very good it's always a
great feeling being back here on the
carpet speaking to you hearing the fans
because it means we finished it means
the movie is done except that you're
never done I read in an interview that
you gave that you are always thinking
Farina for movies ahead even when you're
talking about one that's being really so
what's going on in your head right now
we released an ant-man trailer today
which went over very well we're still in
the cutting room on that we start
filming Civil War in three weeks so that
those are many other things but this is
a moment that we look forward to on all
the movies when we can share what we've
been working on for years and years with
the whole world and for you what made
you say Ultron is the right the right
villain for this movie well that was a
conversation we had with Joss Whedon on
the set of Avengers 1 and it really was
Joss who said if we get to do this again
it's got to be Ultron because he fits
into the technological world of Tony
Stark because the vision who's another
important character his origins are sort
of linked with Ultron's so and when you
ask the Avengers to assemble it has to
be for a very very good reason
absolutely they are a global
peacekeeping force you guys shot all
around the world can you tell me a
little bit about what it was like
shooting in so many different locations
it was wonderful I mean we had so much
support in Johannesburg South Africa
particularly in Seoul Korea amazing
support when you see the sequences that
we shot particularly in Seoul it's
really incredible opens up the scope of
the whole movie speaking of which I'm I
heard that you guys use drones and
remote-control cars to shoot in Seoul we
use all sorts of tricks yeah but there
was some drone photography which at the
time you could only do in a few places
and I think you're going to start to see
in a lot of films now but this was the
first time we used it in that sequence
and we actually used it in some of the
end battle sequences as well and you
know you are just as much a fan as you
are a producer of all these movies for
you who are you roasted which character
are you most excited to see coming to
life on screen in we haven't seen yet or
that well Ant Man because that's the one
I'm living with right now but also I've
been asked that question many times over
the years and my answer almost always is
Doctor Strange and now we have a doctor
strange and Benedict cumberpatch we
start shooting in November it's very
exciting and I can't wait to actually
show him to the world max I cannot wait
alright patience patience we'll see this
movie first then the next year
good thanks very much have a wonderful
time tonight enjoy it thank you bye bye
thanks all right you guys we've gotten a
few min